l'hôpital public en france a subi depuis
des années on ne sait bien maintenant
des réductions de budgets publics
draconiennes on voit aujourd'hui que
l'austérité budgétaire ça tue tout
simplement
donc si elle est française et les
français qui meurent aujourd'hui c'est
aussi et d'abord parce que l'hôpital
public n'a plus les moyens de travailler
correctement depuis des années ça c'est
le premier qu'on l'ait donc la violence
d urgence aujourd'hui c'est un
investissement public massif de manière
à permettre à l'hôpital de limiter la
casse à l'achat massif de machines à
ventiler de matériel médical pour
permettre de sauver des vies maintenant
pendant six mois maintenant il me semble
que c'est la priorité des priorités la
deuxième c'est de permettre aux
françaises et aux français de sortie en
confirmant le compliment comme tels ne
résout pas le problème
le confinement permet juste à partir du
moment où on a raté le coche initial qui
était le dépistage systématique
ce qu'a fait la corée du sud ce café
taiwan ce que nous aurions dû faire à
partir du moment où nous n'avons pas
fait sérieusement nous avons laissé le
virus se répand dans la population
lorsque les autorités publiques se sont
réveillés c'était trop tard donc à ce
moment là la seule option viable c'était
le confinement ce que nous avons fait on
fait également trop tard maintenant le
confinement lui-même ne stoppe pas
l'épidémie
c'est à dire que si demain matin tout le
monde ressort de son domicile ça
recommence d'épidémie reprend de plus
belle avec en plus un système
hospitalier qui est déjà à genoux donc
la question c'est à partir du moment où
on va sortir du confinement pratiquer le
dépistage le plus systématique possible
pour faire ce qu'on aurait dû faire
au tout début la stratégie sud-coréenne
la stratégie taïwanaise qui ont réussi
pour l'instant à refouler la pandémie
sans confinement
donc ça veut dire que la durée le
confirme en tout cas c'est une question
que beaucoup d'entre nous se posent la
durée du confinement elle est liée
essentiellement à notre capacité à faire
des tests
donc les deux facteurs limitants ce sont
deux enzymes qu'il faut produire à toute
vitesse pour faire des tests en masse
les minimes test une fois qu'on aura
produit c'est andy mais il ya un
laboratoire en france fille capable de
le faire à la vente en france est en
train de le faire alors il faudra
s'organiser de manière à faire du
dépistage systématique
manière que les français puissent sortir
de l'enfermement si on ne fait pas ça
soit on reste confinée et on attend
qu'il ya une immunisation collective à
l'intérieur du confinement
ce qui semble devenir la stratégie d'un
certain nombre de zones par exemple aux
états unis mais les petits calculs de
coin de table montre dans ce cas là on
en a pour six mois de confinement
je pense que c'est intenable à la fois
économiquement financièrement
socialement psychologiquement pour la
plupart d'entre eux
[Musique]